hey everybody we might be drunk is
brought to you by sheath underwear if
you're trying to make it through the
summer where in regular boxers it's no
wonder your dong and balls or a big
sweaty mess what you need is sheath with
one pocket for your dick and a separate
pocket for your balls everything stays
cool and Breezy we love this stuff are
you wearing it right now wear right now
what better Ino come on look at that God
what this isn't planned we just wear it
every I love their underwear it's so
best my all my under all my other
turns into swiss cheese I'm walking
around with my balls dangling out little
patch go to sheath underwear. use code
drunk to get 20% off your first order
plus sheath underwear's 100% money back
guarantee that sheath underwear. comom
promo code drunk this guy's a veteran
he's a big comedy fan we love this guy
get sheath underwear support the show
support your balls here here these are
women's all
[Music]
right hey hey hey oh sorry no you go hey
hey wait what's this oh you brought the
dog hey I didn't even notice it he
walked in you didn't even say anything
oh my bad I went right to the seat you
did one of you did one of things I
usually do you're like GH and you walk
in come over no just uh flew in
yesterday went straight to spots and I
had a 10 a.m. pod so I'm I'm how was
that improv show it was gray but I blew
it why well I feel bad I didn't prepare
and it showed really and it was star
stud it was like ker Joe Koy Whitney uh
Fortune fster Deion Cole Craig Robinson
Jeff Dunham representing New York what
the I know I they go do old
material you don't have to burn anything
new I said great I know all that and
then I'm up there going what's that joke
from 2014 how's that end and it went
okay but I forgot three jokes I had I
didn't say thank you to The Improv I I
blew it yeah well we don't we don't like
come up there that's true that's true
but yeah but you still got to say thank
you I guess yeah
ah the ego I was like I got this it's
good to good to have one of those every
once in a while I learned my lesson but
you don't want to learn your lesson on
Netflix with a big shoot they fly out
you know yeah I know I'm ashamed
but it still went okay I just you you
hate to know that you forgot three jokes
you know damn I know maybe they'll edit
it so you look fine all right I hope so
they probably use five minutes of it
anyway but the dog looks good the dog is
f can you introduce us to your oh this
this is this is a lady I'm seing uh
Pooch oneeyed Winnie and uh lost and eye
dude a pug with a touch of
Chihuahua surviving on the streets of LA
she was found so that's why she has one
eye cuz she probably some tough
La Chihuahua was like hey mama hey mama
out on skid R doing Fentanyl and uh I
mean she was probably had to fight
for her life so she does she'll be last
night she's in her bed and I just like
touch her and she goes ah like this like
like she'll snap on you I'm like oh that
doesn't go away yes where you you
know flashbacks streets they're in her
well you Matt was what were you just
saying to me about your cat oh no that
cat is a stray and she will only sleep
in cardboard boxes
whoa he said his cat's astray he took
her in and she only sleeps in cardboard
boxes now he just said that he's on on
mic oh thank you not right now wow all
right what are you what are you dress
like a special needs kid what's going on
here you I'm trying to class it up a
little bit okay I am Matthew okay well
this yeah this dog is great though fun
we literally play the thing I just we
just took a cab up here and she
loses it at rap music she hates rap
music that's
adorable maybe she's singing along she
probably knows Biggie or one of them La
Street dog yeah she she she yeah she
knows Tupac she goes way back this is Su
kns she's she's 16 dude oh yeah an old
lady walked up to me on the street the
other day and she goes I hope I look
that good when I'm 16 I was like you
won't it means you're 112 you'll be long
dead you know yeah exactly trying to be
polite but come on I'm G look up rap
music from 16 years ago and see how she
reacts to it okay 16 years ago really
2002 20077 see I can't do math all right
this is exciting I hope she pulls out a
shank and cut
somebody she probably was getting like
held down by three dogs and getting
raped and she had to just shank her way
out yeah she got out of there she fought
her way out good for her she's a badass
all right here we go now make sure it's
Los Angeles based oh get California Love
on let's see what happens yeah that's
all that's '90s
Cali play Loud too are we going to get
demonetized right now you got to play
what 16 seconds they'll give
you wow I forgot about the whole Mad Max
thing she's really
dead oh it's popping up
uhoh oh man the flashbacks are
swirling remember that night fight on
saula yeah she's getting a little
anxious little
angsty she she needs a for that she was
she was at that barbecue for that she
needs a little treat here
winie this is great A she'll be
that up in about 8
minutes come
on she all right she's got like no teeth
man she's old as you love older
women holy moly yeah I think the rap
thing pissed her off I know I think that
was a bad idea wow she's like an old
conservative she's like turn that
off she burning NW records with Nancy
Reagan oh boy one eye one eye is
always kind of funny yeah yeah it's
funny it's like it's like cuz it's
badass you think of like Nick Fury you
think of uh what what's her name from
Kill Bill Daryl Hannah yeah Dan cruncha
well he's but it was like from the war
right he was a marine yeah I mean so
it's always like a
badass backstory yep and then just a
little pug I know pull up the
Men in Black Dog cuz that's what this
reminds me of pugs pugs are
great great and great for com like the
tongue out I mean it's it's
gold there he is I wonder who voiced
that guy cuz he killed it man in Black
solid up oh the first one's great it is
oh yeah the dog had a
name a or J Rip Torn looks like a bul
dog he
does
[Music]
hey I have to put a pee pad down she
she's getting moist seeing that hot pug
in a tuck dude she that's the thing is
she still starts like I take her on
a walk and a big dog will walk by and
she was just go like and they always
back down cuz she's got that street in
her right but the one time they call her
Bluff she's dead of course she's
got nothing to back it there's no teeth
left I mean she can't bite she got like
one tooth yeah like that day of a TA bit
right
Taffy and plus she got a little uh
little weight around the gut there I
mean she's out of touch yeah out of
shape out of shape she's losing it but
she's cute as a button and uh wishing we
could get her on the mic we' hear some
of these stories I got a crazy
story for you please cuz I was in LA the
week before you I do Whitney Cummings
podcast and uh afterwards we're doing
spots so she drives me to the spot on
the same show she does a phone call with
Rodney Dangerfield's wife whoa so she
was you know they're just on the phone
they're just chatting I was like oh and
Whitney's like oh she's like the coolest
person she said like really loved him
you could tell she really loved Rodney
and we're on the phone and afterwards I
started doing the impression in the car
and Whitney's like you know she's
cracking up she's like I didn't know you
love Rodney like that I was like oh I
love Rodney you know she no I know you
liked him but I was like oh no he's like
maybe my favorite you know and uh she's
like we should call her back you should
do the bits on the phone so I start
doing the impression and she's cracking
up I'm getting her laughs I know that
could have gone real her with a r
getting
triggered wow oh my God what would be
worse than fully committing to a bit and
her being like he's dead what the
is wrong with you but no but she was
cool about and she like was like oh I
really loved him I woke up every morning
like laughing and happy he like made me
so happy
and was just so coolz she is like a hot
younger woman so you never know but
clearly the love was real and then I'm
do I do a bit I do you know I was an
ugly kid my mother never breastfed me
she told me she like me as a friend and
she laughs and she goes there was
another breastfeeding joke I go you know
I was an ugly kid my mother she breasted
me through a straw I'll tell you I was
ugly she goes that's it I've never heard
that one and then she goes I got a
Ronnie Dangerfield joke that no one has
ever heard you want to hear it oh and I
was like of course he's coming out of
brain surgery we don't know if he's
going to make it he says before like
I don't know like if I don't make
it uh you know hello Buu yo perf and he
says if you know Rodney Dangerfield I'm
telling a story about Dangerfield's wife
is telling me over the phone and she
goes I uh he says to me look if I don't
make it like what do I do I I I
need my mind to be sharp and he's going
to brain surgery he comes out they don't
know if he's okay and the doctor
everyone's in there the doctor goes uh
Rodney did you cough anything up and he
goes yeah 500 bucks last week to a wh oh
my God everyone in the room
erupts in laughter like can you imagine
just like it's like off the cuff wow
just like is he dead yeah it's literally
like the Undertaker just like popping up
you know wow also like what a great wife
she's like oh the thing it's a
joke it's a joke but good for her to
roll with it oh yeah doesn't look like
Winnie oh I can see it I can see it yeah
the big eyes they're com they have
comical faces for sure yeah you know the
uh the J Leno Rodney story when he's in
bed yeah what is that again he's laying
in bed you know could die at any moment
all the pipes the tubes are all hooked
up and the wife goes Jay just put your
finger in his hand you know just to let
him know you're here because he couldn't
respond or anything and uh he goes
Rodney he puts the finger in hand he
goes Rodney you're my favorite comic you
mean the the most to me and there's one
thing I got to tell you that's not my
finger and he said Rodney like went like
a like a twitch and he's like I think he
got it I yeah I heard that story and I
think Joan was in there with him too
right it was it was I don't know maybe
Jay Leno and Joan were both in there wow
what a room holy hot show it's a
hot hosital I know but it's a good
roster Lena was supposed to be on this
La show and he he had to back out I was
I was hoping to meet him yeah because I
know he's a fan of yours and I'm a huge
fan of his I want him on the Pod I feel
like he's got I mean his 80s stories I
just want to hear I remember reading
this book when I was like a kid remember
that one leading with my chin oh yeah
that was a good one that was great he
old school he's got all the history like
he he stopped in front of the car he got
hit by a car during the the comedy
strike in the the70s OR 80s for a guy
who loves cars he has had bad luck with
cars that's true but I guess that comes
with the obsession sometimes he might be
the toughest guy on the planet gets his
face burned off and then he's back at
work doing jokes about it and that's
what you do like some people are
insecure like there was that one
comedian who had a weird chin and got it
removed and repaired and he like none of
us know his name right Leno's got a
weird chin he's like I'm the chin guy
yeah that's what you do have you seen
the Lou and and Leno fight on on the
tonight's show it was great great we can
we play that or we we going to get pull
it up play that it's and Leno on the
tonight's show and it's playful but they
go back and fourth in a way where you're
like I think Louis's kind of going at
him a little bit being like I got this
guy and Leno's kind of like no you
I can still I can still have fun exactly
CU everybody's like oh you're the the
corny Tonight Show kind of mainstream
guy but no no he had some Venom inum
dude I you know what else we got to pull
up at some point maybe on a patreon or
maybe just like you know after our guest
we have a special guest coming in not
just when another special guest but uh
we could play it after have you ever
seen Mark Summers versus Bert Reynolds
on on what no we'll play save that for
save that for later have that queued up
let's watch let's watch the Louis one
first it shouldn't be hard to find Louis
and Leno fighting tonight show that it's
it's later he's older Lou Lou's like at
the peak of Lou yeah like no no no it
wasn't 200 it was it was like at that
run where every time Lou did couch you
were like you have to see this yes yes
everything's amazing and no one cares
the cell phone it's going to space
that's what started it I feel like I
think that's kind of what broke him I
got it yeah that was a lot also that bit
in the end of the HBO special with his
daughter but why oh brilant brilliant
joke oh it's on YouTube I'm on YouTube
you're on premium oh dude we got to get
got to get these Boomers out of here we
got to get some Asian twink to come in
here and really gamer it up find an
Asian uh intern
please make him trans I want a full
headset the video game chair we just
turn we just turn to salamona for the
next episode it's an Asian there in the
same shitty
outfit he may not be trans but his name
is TR hey there you go I'll take it
that's pretty
good I like it what are we drinking
today there fatty oh well I'll introduce
it when the guests come oh yeah or you
guys want to start now we can start now
no we'll save it for the guest let's I
think this is it 2006 uh maybe he I
think Lou in a t-shirt I think this is
it no this isn't it is not it no all
right it can't be that hard but I don't
want to I don't want it was like it was
a definite heat check from Louie where
Louie was murdering so much that he was
like I'm G to with the host and he
so and he did it to Fallon too and it
was uh they were good yeah they were I
mean they were Fallon it was like a
little rough where cuz he was like I
told them not to hire you remember that
one oh that was crazy that was one I was
like this is kind of mean yeah yeah cuz
he was like you're too cute you were too
cute I hated how cute you were the girls
liked you and you're like Lou you're
just owning up that you're a
I know you know you're a jealous
bitter Guy this is it most heterosexual
outfit I've ever seen so he get a little
Zing about his outfit he said what he
say he got a real sexual outfit on okay
most heterosexual outfit I've ever seen
hetosexual heterosexual you look like a
man who tried to dress himself it is
this oh I didn't know Leno started it a
little bit okay this is it maybe this
isn't it you look like a cop is it
inside out hold on look like protecting
the president well this is my job this
is my un You Are by the way you I hope I
can say this without insulting you
you're no you're the weirdest looking
person on the planet
Earth he is weird that's very I don't
mean that as a all just nobody I can't
describe the fact that I have a full
head
oh and Lou like oh wait I didn't know we
were going
here but it's it's fun yeah that the
wrong way Lou has a great response I
just don't have to cover my chin cuz I'm
proud of
[Laughter]
it woo that's two that's a onew
punch if you weren't famous and you
robbed a bank and the dude was
describing you to like a police sketch
art yeah he'd be like no seriously what
did he look like
that's a great
joke nobody looks like you I can't I
can't believe I'm looking at you all the
time oh he's back on the ropes now how's
Leno going to get out of it and and if
you rob the bank what I keep the money
and be happy no that's it they got out
wow Lou Lou were definitely more
creative it's a Tonight Show audience
like to me the funniest line is they'd
be like no what does he really look like
but that didn't get the pop right true
but it's way more clever it's a Tonight
Show crowd full head of hair is e not I
don't say easy but it's a it's an
obvious sight gag you can see it right
there but it's fun yeah the sketch art
is a little more High concept but that's
that's Louis but this is when you could
kind of be a dick and it was fun like it
this it didn't feel contentious no no no
not at all and I'm sure they went
backstage in the commercial like that
was great that was a great moment
however the Steve Summers one Mark
Summers Mark Summers let me look it up
but a long it's it's long we might just
want to say let's let's say put a pin in
that and save it for the Ys cuz if find
it now cuz it's going to take you half
hour to find it that's true H any word
from the guest I don't want to oh God
okay but he knows he's coming all right
all right and he knows the floor and
everything right okay good I'll tell you
I got upgraded on the flight back that I
got that L out they didn't fly you first
class Netflix I know well you
know they they nickel and dime how much
they paid you you should have bought a
first class ticket well now here's the r
you can't take it with you that's true
but I had your voice in my head and I
said I was looking at the flight I was
like oh man I'm like
38D that's an LA flight 6 hours six and
change let me look at the first class
there was two available and I was $88.99
to upgrade to first class and I already
paid you know 400 for the ticket or
whatever I like Ah that's pricey but
it's a long flight it's Netflix you know
they're paying pretty well it I'll
buy it pushed send this is rare for me I
never do this I push purchase and then I
got the email you purchased your ticket
first class woo all right then I got I I
checked the app and it goes you've been
upgraded oh and I was like well wait a
minute maybe they got confused I've been
upgraded I bought the ticket I bought
the ticket on accident I didn't need it
I got upgraded I lost the
money I got upgraded for free he was say
you got to look at it though you would
have bought it anyway I guess you're
right the upgrades a roll of a dice what
a kick in the dick you're making enough
you should you should here's how I look
at the first classet this it's a lot of
money here's how I look at it though
you're making enough on the road you
you're on the road as much as you are
you want to look forward to going to
work that's how I look at it I look
forward when I have a first class ticket
I look forward and I didn't this is a
very new thing I was I was middle seat
coach for a hot decade plus I'm 63 I
didn't enjoy that that's hell you
know I'm sure that did not help my
neck but uh you know now I'm
like I this is a work trip it's a
write off I want to I want to be excited
to get on that trip right and that L
flat I can to lay down I'll it's
nice watch a movie yeah yeah you're
right but I I couldn't help looking to
4B at the czs who was reading a
book and doing Sudoku and going go I
paid for that
I almost took a roll off her tray
just cuz I wanted to eat it just to get
something back you what you should do
though is just be like this is this
worked out that's how you have to look
also think about how much you got paid
from Netflix yeah that's crazy
that Netflix doesn't just get your
flight I know I might just send him the
bill be like here you go like play dumb
there you go you guys are covering this
right yeah of course okay I think that's
an easy email back uh no we're not yeah
I don't think you're just get a
Jedi Mind tricked into paying for but
they should I remember back in the day
doing late night sets on like cordon and
they wouldn't pay for even like a coach
ticket and I was like wow that's
up I think cuz it's not but then you
just like you route it with I'd R it
with like a weakend at like the punch
line or something so it wasn't like a
waste but I think that's crazy it's CBS
but that's how much money they were
hemorrhaging right that's why they're
not doing a late night host anym
20 million a year we all just assume TV
they have zillions and zillions they
were Heming that much money wow
and they're bringing it back I think
Hardwick's going to host no did you hear
that may it's just I don't think they
have a host I think they're just doing
at midnight oh okay oh that's right okay
the first step before they go full on AI
I know right they just get no host and
they're like this is I watch some shows
and I'm like this is well TV
sucks I mean look no no offense to late
night we did it for years but like even
Conan's like I'm doing a podcast this
shit's over it feels a little Antiquated
like who sits down and watches Fallon oh
here we go at 11: p.m. I know you know
bowl of popcorn oh who's on jwow oh boy
I can't wait you know who gives a
is jayw still on I threw out a crazy
name
I think she was on back when Lou was on
that Leno yeah you might be right she
had a lot of surgery but you know uh
all these shows like I dat a
girl who's like I come home and like
bravoos on I'm like get this off my
TV my does same I don't want to like cut
this six months later you're watching no
it's been 6 months I don't watch I don't
I there's another one where it's just
like it's called below deck and it's
just people yting holy are these
boring like I I this was
before this is how we got to AI this is
literally like we get dumb
uninteresting idiots with no Talent it
costs us less you don't have to pay
writers so now you're already not paying
writers we have the show I'm not saying
you can't have like look people like
reality but you can't deny this is how
we got here of course of course it was
the end it was the death of TV I mean
like this is it cake who the hell would
do that show I just taped an
episode but you know what's funny we I
was there with it was me and Christina P
oh I love p and we had we had a lot she
loves the show though cuz she has kids
and they W it's a family show that guy
Mike dayve from SNL hosted he's funny
he's awesome and also I was making jokes
like none of these are going to make the
show like literally like one of them
they were like this is a hard choice
between these two and I was like I was
like yeah this is harder than Kevin
spacy to Bar Mitzvah silence Dead
Silence what yeah yeah oh yeah well he
was laughing but like that you know the
the you tell the crew was like no now
you see this is another reason why TV's
dying it's not just because of the the
the F and jwow it's cuz comedy
that's the best joke on the show I
guarantee family show I kept digging a
hole at one point I was like I mean both
you you're Killers it's like choosing
between Menendez brothers you know a
that's great I kept digging a hole and
I'm like they're not going to like we're
not using any of these we got to get
some grip to get the footage just post
that that'll go viral what happened
to me on AGT is that they cut all my
funny and then um like like you
know offset and then you're uh I had an
editor like DM like Twitter messag me
like holy I'm I'm laughing my ass
up I can't believe you're like you're
making jokes about like you know muff
diving and like
yeah like how the hell I'm like yeah
they hated me I like that's probably why
they were like get rid of this
guy well we know from experience you do
these morning shows like uh hello
Cincinnati or whatever at 6:00 in the
morning and you do you play ball and you
go yeah thanks Maria this is a beautiful
city you bomb but if you go up and go
hey my dad molested me or que it up
whatever it is and they're like this is
horrible but you sell the tickets that
is the morning show Playbook it's like
chapter one were you
molested were you not pretend you were
it still hits yeah yeah they that lady
hits you in the back with a clipboard
like so any funny stories and you're
like yeah so I was my dad was you know
in the the goog and he me every
day or whatever it is and they're like
well we can't do anything so I'm like
but that's funny that's it's also hard
cuz I have a you know I have a person
who books me on this and every time
she's like I I can't ask them for
live TV or they know you're going to
with them totally you just have to
hope it's live yes yes it's so true but
that is cake I mean that's those are
great lines they were they were
incredibly talented though the people
make it that's what we're talking about
no Talent these people are incredibly
talented the back the no the people
making the cakes oh those people are
amazing God because they're not only
making a great tasting cake but it looks
incredible I was like I I couldn't
believe like how much work that must
have taken and then it's also tough
because you know one of the people gets
eliminated when we're on the show and
your instinct is to make a joke but Like
This Woman's crying I'm like I'm like
this is like their dream so I had
to like pull back on a couple cuz I'm
like I don't want to be a but I'm like
I'm so close to being like I've seen
that look before but you have to like
pull back and don't don't say right
cuz she's incredibly talented and she
and this is a setback for her sure sure
damn those people are amazing we've been
eliminated off reality shows it sucks
dude I did a Last Comic Standing I made
it to the semi-finals I got some kind of
illness H pylori so I'm up there and I'm
like I'm doing well and I'm like oh I
can't remember my joke my brain was all
foggy and then Rosanne goes what
happened you know they have to do the
judges panel what happened years later
you said that to her yeah what happened
I was like ambion but uh she was like
what happened the first set you were so
good and it went well and this set you
were a little off and I was like well I
got AIDS and it killed and then the they
were like like the guy in the back was
like what are you doing and then Keenan
Ivory wein said something and he goes
yeah this just wasn't your best uh your
best performance I go well I appreciate
that Damon that got a laugh but they cut
all this out and I was zinging the posts
and I was like oh I felt so good like
hey I was funny there even though my set
sucked and they don't play any of it
yeah that's the worst cuz those are all
great lines and you're like all I have
here I'm going down all I have is like
you're Tony Montana and Scarface
you're getting shot a million times
you're just trying to take a few people
with you I mean essentially all you have
is him getting shot in the back of the
head you don't have the cool like I'm I
went out like a g though right say hello
to my little Zinger that's all you got
and then you get shot in the face yeah
that's uh that's oh by the way I
got a hot wreck for you guys you might
have seen this I did I did bur's podcast
when I was in LA and I hit him with
Manhunter as a wreck and he and and he
hit which I love dude you love that
movie but then he hits me with uh it's a
I didn't know it was a John Houston
movie It's called Fat City never Fat
City it's with young Jeff Bridges he's
like 22 he's a boxer in Stockton
California and then we get uh Stacy ke
who's like the washed up boxer love dude
it's
good it's a dark movie it is not a
feel-good movie did you watch it it's
incredible oh really yeah thank you I'm
in I have never heard of this it's
heartbreaking but it's so good
did Bert let you get a word in no bill
bur oh oh okay got it I think he said
Bert Bill bur Loves Movies song that
sounds like one of the people in the
movie The Ear professional wow I'm
already in just the font and the oh look
at that picture I it John Houston it's
so cool to watch a guy like kind of near
the end of his career directing cuz
you're like oh you just know how to make
a great movie you just know how to how
to not there's none of the I read
Ebert's review after and it was like
some of the critics of this movie say
that it's not you know there's not
enough suspense he's like but that
wouldn't work for a movie like this this
is so real this is like it's such a
gritty real movie it reminds me a little
bit like a little bit of the wrestler oh
but uh but it's not like it's it's a
very different I mean the the the you
know the bleakness I mean I'm not giving
anything away once you start watching
this you're like this ain't going to be
a Feelgood film what is Fat City can we
know what town that is I it's Stockton
California oh got it got it um Nate Diaz
and the director he do you see his fight
uh no with Jake Paul oh yeah yeah I lost
some money on that one did you you bet
on Nate di oh don't don't say he hasn't
seen it of course I mean he's what is
this the Sopranos
no I've seen it I mean oh okay sorry I
thought you were like don't spoil it no
no no you get two weeks my head at it
you get two weeks not get two weeks even
two weeks no I've seen no I'm saying
I've seen I just shaking in my head at
like ridiculous yeah bad fight but Paul
Paul's underrated people go he's a
YouTube Star Mickey Mouse Club but no
he's a hell of a puncher he can fight I
I was just going to say about Houston
like director at the end of their career
is like they're in don't give a
mode criticism critics what the reviews
are can you imagine like if you didn't
have that inner critic in your mind what
you could create or like worry about
what critics are going to say or oh you
just know how to make a flick you know
yeah great I'm I'm all in heyy Sally
baby come on in we're rolling oh we're
rolling right now we usually do a little
intro here yeah hey hey folks we might
be drunk as brought to you by game time
going to concerts is amazing but buying
a ticket is a frustrating son of an
onion it's expensive and you have to
plan so far in advance stop distress
with game time it's the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
Music Theater and comedy near you they
have killer deals on last minute tickets
so you can buy your ticket this
afternoon to go out on the town tonight
we love game time this guy goes to a
million Sports shows I go to a bunch of
concerts we love it you got to do it the
fees it's all raking in they they they
screw you so by the way we caught that
you didn't go to a lot of sports uh
games cuz you called them shows
oh can't wait to go to the Nick
show later tonight all right all right
well we'll see you at the ballp park you
can even get an image of your seat view
so you can always know what to expect
that's nice snag the ticket without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app make an account use code drunk
for $20 off your first purchase again
create an account redeem with code drunk
for $20 off your first purchase terms
apply download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed love it he what's up what's
up man I got to do live on the airology
oh you're fine you're good9 Street for
20 minutes no I know I was in a cab too
I got out and I walked with this little
but then I had microphone oh
I just jumped out of my car and ran here
oh jeez two two Avenues over I had I was
my assistant just running and get in the
car in the middle of traffic wow you
know that's how we you know just I'm
just New Yorker that's what we do
explain the shirt David arette ruined
your life oh you don't know you I never
told you that story oh baby here we go
really I never told you that story I
love David arette oh I hate the
guy oh really yeah I hate him I
literally hate
him I saw him we would fight if I saw
him we would fight really yeah the kid
call it on site can you not watch can
you like not watch Scream you hate him
that much yeah I I Saw Scream but before
we get in what are we drinking here this
is well for cell that's a stroll through
the garden for you guys that's a stumble
through the garden M oh why is it a
stroll stroll that's not alcoholic I'll
take a stumble big time I'll take I'll
take a double stumble I will say I talk
to Matt I told him I didn't really need
to drink at this hour unless you guys
wanted to I'm fine with it but then he
said no no big deal but I'll tell you
the morning I've had make that a double
make that a fall flat on your
face in in the garden oh say much I got
no what what is the alcohol in there
vodka that's fine he's coming in hot
today coming hot there we go I like to
hear it there we go but before we get
into the story what what are the
ingredients the ingredients are hibiscus
blueberry
basil uh a little bit of Ginger a little
honey everything so basically the stroll
through through the garden is just
everything in the garden a little lemon
everything else and then we add a good
healthy very healthy dose of vodka in
there can we can we get a little bowl
one for the dog as well a little a
little pup Bowl absolutely did you
notice Doug I did yeah what tell tell us
to David first of all I love the new
studio really I haven't been here since
you guys had the new studio you guys
really I mean this is an excellent
excellent job this guy right here that
is that is something else this is a nice
room thank you sir it's comfortable it's
climate controlled it's spacious it's
it's it's stylish I will say your studio
bit of a let down I went down there
downtown you got a million dollars D Roa
is going to die soon you might as well
uh Spruce it up a little bit huh cheers
you're 100% correct hey I don't know
have a studio I have a room that I
turned the camera on in I got you you
know what I'm saying I got to be out of
that place in December so I didn't want
to like go too too hard in dude this is
excellent not bad sh oh that's
good syrup this is delicious I don't
even taste of vodka yeah that's the you
well theirs is the stumble through the
garden yours is the stumble around the
garden what does that mean it's a little
stronger I want to do full on my
face yeah put the whole thing these two
thought the Pod was on Monday and they
terrified me cuz I I wasn't looking at
my phone I look like 40 minutes later
that was my fault yeah but this is this
is how salacuse is with me uh
Matt I'm at Chipotle taking orders you
have two minutes Norman missed it on my
way and I go wait we're on Thursday I
thought I don't have that we have a pod
today Matt writes back bad Intel good
burrito I don't know what any of this
means the hell are you talking about I
write back I said I S said August 31st
Mark you said you were in LA today am I
missing something Matt salak wres back
dates got crossed what very vague you're
like a today cross you're like a marine
but yeah but but this this three texts
to give me the we don't have a pod today
right right right that was Monday yeah
yeah that was on me I told him we had a
pod CU I thought we did and I sh up with
my kid we were both there now he's
divorced that's your no it's a girl
scenes dog but she's at work and I was
like I I hang with the guy during the
day yeah yeah what's the dog's name
Winnie Winnie onee Winnie I or e y or i
e uh w i n n i e okay like Winnie Cooper
yeah dude I know Winnie Cooper wait wait
really
matician yeah wow yeah not growing pain
yeah no uh Wonder Years her name is uh
is Danica mckel very pretty lady yeah
very pretty gal everyone's crushed back
in the day you got that right I'm dying
to hear this David arette story he's a
piece of but why is he a piece of
and I don't have any qual saying
that's why I made this goddamn shirt lay
it
on back in the day I end up seeing some
one of his exes and courney Cox what's
that Courtney Cox no no no no not
Courtney Cox but um there he is and and
I saw him at a party and they came up to
me we had a couple of words I I didn't
know him I had nothing against him coule
words um this has got to be
now
200 12 oh wow this is goes back yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying you never
heard the story no no yeah this this
doxed me what yes he put my
stuff because you dated a girl he he he
didn't say it was cuz I he did it for
another reason was his other no no I
mean like he he did he didn't say it was
because of that but he leaked my stuff
on Twitter what yeah yeah what a psycho
I know I know well doesn't he have a
mental stuff right I I don't know that I
don't I I don't know anything about his
mental stuff but I think he's got some
he's bipolar no no no that that I have
nothing about I just have the gripe
about how he he did that to me and like
I've literally been like waiting to see
him at events just so I could just go up
to him and and yeah what I mean he's
he's he's a real piece of yeah well
we got your back this guy cool
at all them all the whole
family I hate the whole family actually
yeah well that's crazy you can't a
celebrity doing that to another
celebrity you should know you know come
on also though also though uh completely
around you made that up
yeah I'm on my faing the garden
right now I'm actually joker I'm
actually bring the boys in all right I'm
I'm a big fan of his he wrestles and
this is a wrestling I'm actually I'm
actually a yeah it was bum for I'm like
I love scream that's one of my
favor I love David and you know you know
it's speaking of wrestling you know it's
a you know it's an underrated
flick with him ready to rumble with the
that's what I'm saying he's a wrestler
he actually wrestles once in a while and
he really sacrifices his body really
yeah he's look up some of his mattres
he's I mean fully covered in blood oh
he's bipolar yeah I don't know I made
that up too I was like soon I was like
all right I'm having fun but then you
like mental I'm like no no I don't know
nothing about the bipolar holy I
love how we went from like on
his dead trans sister to like did you
see ready to rumble
it I'm a fan by the way you know someone
is not going to get to the end of that
story they're just going to they're
going to be like well him and they
do him yes holy I was going to wait
till the end but then I thought that and
I was like let me just say something
that was incredible man you held that
commitment yeah I wish I thought of a
better story but on the moment on the
floor think of what he that was killer
yeah he's actually I think a very very
sweet guy I would look I look forward to
meeting him one day yeah maybe this will
get back to him and maybe he'll he'll
he'll have a mercy that's crazy you
never met him he's going to himself
for the first three minutes of the story
like what the hell holy did I do
that wow and Courtney Cox was a real
piece yeah pull up the photo of her in
in a Ace Ventura I feel like she doesn't
get her D cuz she got in the Jennifer
Aniston Shadow yeah yeah she had she had
her own thing going on oh yeah for sure
she was hot in those Scream movies she
also has a rasp and let me tell you
something right now you can't buy a rasp
you either have it or you don't and it's
it's not common good point look I mean
look at that look at those shoulders the
eyes I mean hot to Molly yeah also she
was the girl in Bruce springsteed video
that was like when she was super young
right like that was her first like
before we knew her those are the years I
liked she got on she got on stage with
the boss wow that I think that broke her
like dancing in the Dancing in the Dark
is that was that it dark look at that oh
so
cute
she's another example and I I like the
wait a minute but she's an example
of like too much surgery just let it let
it
age all right I'm
getting she's a beautiful woman La is a
up place it is it
is ah he can't play the boss what are
you old old do that's yeah so
was this I mean it must have been
planned right oh this is the video yeah
so he like cast she was cast she was
cast totally but this is at a real
concert so they were duping everyone
else there or is that not a real concert
that's a real concert it is I think Plan
full she wouldn't be she'd be
herself man he was a h so everybody
there just thought that he pulled
someone on stage but he was actually had
ulterior motives oh yeah it's like a
couple Comics we know they have plants
all right wait click on the one oh oh
yeah I'll tell you later speaking of
garden running through the garden who's
got the plants let's talk about doing
the garden well think speaking of that
uh May me think that Guns and Roses song
The Garden
I don't know play beginning no the
garden play just the beginning welcome
to the
Garden we got our cat Guns and Roses was
awesome some say the best
American band I don't know about that
but I don't know about know there
concert no I did I did recently though
like year five years ago I heard he's
weird now I thought he I I didn't know
what to expect and he had the same exact
pipes dude he didn't hold back bless the
man yeah love to hear it yeah he was a
he was a cute guy through the word
around quite a bit get out of here in
the song even slash was like really what
song was that H give it a goo I can't
remember heard this
oh
yeah I kind of dipped out after like
they they did that like 10 minute song
Yeah remember right yeah like I after
that I dipped out I I liked uh appetite
and then I like lies lies lies yep yep
yep yes I have a fun trivia about one of
those you know the song that says uh I
used to love her oh I had to kill her
you know and then he goes she's buried
right in my backyard yeah I found out
years later he's talking about his dog
wow how about that I thought you were
going to say Phil Spectre wrote that
line that's
crazy oh you going to play the
n-word yeah we'll cut this yeah know
maybe we don't play this just proing my
point yeah we believe you slash was
black it's okay we didn't play The
Michael Richards rant either talked
about it SL was uh something half black
half Jew I yeah he was exotic he was a
hunk he's in the Hanukkah song that's
the only reason I know dude you know who
the was at my show in La I ran an
hour the Chili Peppers were at
my show shut up I'm not kid all of them
about everyone but flee wow and I'm kind
of bum cuz flee is such a Hoops guy I
feel like we would have hit it off oh is
he you didn't know no Tom takar
is opening my show and he was like dude
Anthony Kus and all the chili peppers
are in the crowd and I was what what
they didn't come back no apparently Tom
tak's friend is out there and he's like
Anthony Kus is looking for a merch stand
I was like I didn't bring merch and I
was like what the we could have got
him like someone send him a shirt cting
us right now no no and then he
docks me no he no he was no he was they
were at the show and I was like someone
find them they like we can't find them I
was like God damn it I mean did did you
did you find out if he went through the
agency to get tickets now I just picture
Anthony keus like literally on like you
know Ticket Master like all right I got
he's like these fees are outrageous I
can't believe wow it's crazy that he
would go to a show just cuz he's like so
famous he went that's about La yeah you
do a show in I guess it can happen in
New York too but La is like crazy so
many people live there oh you could have
met Kus I could have met Kus I picture
him in his tidy whes just from that
concert Kus I I uh bitched out on saying
hello to him one time at at at an event
too he sitting right in front of me wow
and I just was like that's Anthony Kus
what is this oh that's a shot of that
we're going to calm s down real quick oh
okay shot this a shot of this yes okay
I'm I'm calm now yeah yeah we're all
right don't try to get us Hammer there
oh that's literally my job okay I'm
ready whenn you guys OD but yeah that
Kus he's a he's a fun guy and they
they've been doing this for four Decades
of just rocking out ironically mostly
shirtless that's true do you have any
actual he still has a great B oh yeah do
you have any actual ual celebrity beef
um Jesus do I probably not not me no I
can't if one doesn't come to mine
immediately right I probably don't I can
make another one up if you
want I heard you and Fred
Savage not not friends but you found out
that I was with Winnie and oh yeah she
is a did you know that she's like a
she's a published off
mathematician writes books about math
cuz she always assume she's cute and
she's in a show so she must be an idiot
not an idiot but just like ditsy not a
mathematician yeah exactly that guy you
see that guy Ben mcken from Ben McKenzie
from the OC wrote a book on
crypto and it's like kind of taken off
really pull it up yeah well he's like
the Hawkeye from The OC exactly
that's my point you just assume they're
all vapid yeah so he wrote a book about
Pro crypto no anti- crypto he's like so
the guy from the OC took it upon himself
to write an anti-financial crypto book
he was and it's taken he was an
economics major he's not like he's not a
dumb guy I think he like knows economics
he was like I'm writing a book on this
yeah but if I knew about crypto you
couldn't pay me enough to write a book
about crypto I know right you know what
I mean like what why would I look at
this guy he's a hunk still yeah he could
still get it there oh yeah and now he's
an author so you got the OC and author
to back it up have you seen the OC oh
yeah I used to rub one out to the ocon
come on dude I don't know about it
really I know it took my it was like it
was that like 90210 yes yes exactly look
at it it was all hot I got you by just a
few years but it's enough for me not to
know the what are you 41 sure all right
all
right a problem dude you get us lit up
in the afternoon you're a stat by the
way front line of the post Staten
Island's trying to secede from New York
City oh boy what's that about that's
been like that forever though they they
giving it another go that's been since
I'm a kid they've been saying how many
years yeah I grew up what does that mean
it's just not a burrow it's a burrow we
get it's like the step kid burrow step
kids I am one but uh no they've been
trying to I guess they just don't feel
like they jive with everybody else which
is the truth yeah well it's a bunch of
cops and firemen I mean I went to Chris
D's house it's like Virginia out there
you know they're all blaring a rich man
from Richmond and they're going to town
what did they say why you pay more taxes
than the rest of the city oh is that
right well actually I don't necessarily
disagree that I don't want to not be a
New Yorker but like uh yeah pay the same
taxes people live inh that makes sense
it's like take it easy a little bit
there right we're we're in the BBS do
you think you're more Jersey or more
Brooklyn that oh good question it's an
amalgamation I would say I would say
more more Jersey actually I would say
that too but I didn't want to say it out
loud yeah damn stepo was trying to lead
an exodus he was trying to pull like a
rogue in Austin move with all of us he
was like come to Sten Island I'm like
I'm not coming I'm not going
remember Comics bought the ferry yeah
what happened with that they they got
jammed up with uh they got jammed up
with permits and stuff like that you
can't just have a floating bar on on the
on the Hudson already has a bar on it
yes I I that's what I agree with that
yelling at the the government I I I want
to start that bar D I want to start that
bar I saw the plans for what they were
trying to do and it's it's amazing
really the plans are amazing it's a
great idea in theory I almost I when I
thought it was going to happen I
contemplated uh asking them if I could
shoot my special on it oh don't
do that to yourself I know I know Norman
did a Tonight Show set on there which is
it was fine because it was during Co I
would not do that
otherwise well I thought it would be
like you know done and the theater would
be in there you know light it up and
have the you know beautiful shots of it
you know that's my kind of my identity
that boat I grew up pretty bad ass yeah
but no neveress I'm doing it the Vic now
like hey the Vic yeah that's me you norm
and Bill hick so we got a good alumni
other people have shot there right
probably yeah I don't know when does
this drop
I think
2028 oh right on there you go 911
tickets go on sale tickets go on sale
the 15th this Friday then is this for uh
Netflix YouTube seeso grinder what are
we talking it's one of a couple grind
maybe a couple of those you you named
okay okay it's I'm choosing between a
couple things baby it's not that it's
not that salacious actually all right
all right but no no uh so the pre-sales
the 13th and 14th the codes no fresh and
then
15th yeah it's December 2nd Saturday
December 2nd you hear that Kus get your
fat ass over to Chicago I better see you
guys I better see the peppers there I
think Chicago's a top three comedy City
proba it's just so good they're just
like good you because you eat those
Midwestern people but also it's still
like a City you hear that
Chicago don't let us down I'm at the
Chicago Theater September 30th
so come the out I don't want to
jizz out of school but Matt R sold out
eight Chicago Theaters
no offense like next year yeah yeah I
know no he's he's doing quite well quite
well there's a lot of horny mils out
there yeah yeah eight that's kind of
nutty it's like 3,500 seats isn't it
that's probably a record of some kind
yeah I well for the record I'll be happy
with one sell oh yeah terrific well
that's how big comedy is now if you get
one sell out you're like I was hoping to
add a show not in a venue that big I'm
cool with one that's true but I know
what you mean sometimes you're in like a
800 seater in a weird City and you're
like just one in Knoxville right you got
to take that W I got to tell you that St
Louis last weekend had a
blast it's called The Factory yeah you
did it how's that backstage though oh my
God you want to live back there pull it
up pull up a picture it's not ideal for
like the ceilings are crazy high but
just the way they treat you and it's so
pretty looking it's got a pageant uh
what's there's I think I did the pageant
when I was there okay a more so a a
music V yes yes Factory in St Louis I do
like when the the upper like the mezine
goes all the way around I love which I
think they had if I remember correctly
they did have that but it was a little
cavernous yeah it's a little cavers but
man it was beautiful beautiful sold out
hot crowd but yeah that ceiling was
definitely too high dude St Louis I mean
we've been playing there for
years there's something about St Louis
where like they drink they're fun they
Blue Collar it's a sports Town there's
there's a lot of good going for it
and the pizza I'm sorry it ain't that
great you guys got to settle down with
this cheese Pro no I don't hate it but
I'm also not like you got to they're so
proud of it I'm like it's fine yeah they
drink so they're such alcoholics that
they think it's good there it is yeah
yeah for yeah I don't I tried it I
didn't think anything of it no offense
but um I was there about a month ago
doing shows and uh I uh I have a busy
schedule and I needed to have get some
weed and uh so I went they sell it there
so I went to an official place there I
bought some weed and I was going to take
it on I bought the max allowance yeah
you know I'm busy you Max out Snoop Dog
yeah exactly Jes so the max allowance
isn't ending crazy it's just like they
don't want to think you're a drug like
700 bucks though that's a lot yeah it's
a lot but you could fly bag with all
that not necessarily so I left there I
left there and I I do like I LEL let you
and I've done it before whatever so I
was like I just looked at it and I was
like ah so I asked around they was like
you're taking a risk but the biggest
thing is that they'll just take it from
you maybe give you a sure you know a
slap on the wrist you bought it legally
whatever right so I realized I bought
like 25 pre-rolls and I was like if it
goes through the X-ray and they see 25
things that look like 25 joints they're
probably going to take it from so I was
like you know I'm going to do I'm going
to go to
FedEx so I went FedEx drug even know it
yeah exactly I went to FedEx I packed it
all up I taped it I paid like 65 bucks
to get it shipped overnight mhm I get
home the next day it's not there the
next day it's not there the next day
it's not there I call I say FedEx I'm
like what's going on I paid 65 bucks so
it's not here I'm leaving I needed it by
today yeah so the guy goes all right
I'll refund you to 65 and I'll try to
get it to you tomorrow okay all right
next morning it comes I get it I open it
up half the weed's missing
oh some GD having
at the FedEx plant said he'll what's he
going to do what going to do what's he
going to do that's pretty literally they
took the the best of it and they took
350 bucks worth only the best of it it
was only it was like medicinal really
strong stuff like that they had and and
and basically it that was the only thing
in there and it smelled like weed and
they were like there's probably weed in
here and if it is I'm going to take it
out when they saw it was all weed
they're like I had to leave some right
they take that back up and I got it
half empty so somebody what if they were
like look he's going to get arrested if
it's 700 but if it's
350 legal they like yeah I'm sure they
were looking out for
him wait Mark you point it up at Mitch
hbert cuz he has that famous joke like
you know I said the joke yeah yeah
that's why I pointed at
him thanks for the recap you remember
when he said Mitch Mitch Hedberg had
this famous joke it goes like this and
he said wait do you remember when Mitch
Hedberg had that famous joke
that there you go but now two things I
was so mad I was like cuz there was no
there's going to be no justice no no you
got I was like I might indict
myself and just get him in what if you
just check the bag I don't know what end
happen what would they do if you checked
the bag you'd be fine I fly with drugs
all the time they have that little even
if you have a lock on a bag you have the
TSA key they open it they could probably
do the same I just like why even
bother you know so I just did that and I
was like this son of a I just
don't know if it was on the St Louis end
or the you know my our Louis I'm going
through security coming back from
Calgary I did a really fun show
in Calgary with Dan Soder and Nick
Offerman great out doors Fest shout out
great show I'm coming back and uh going
through security the guy takes my I had
a Theo gun with me a massage gun the
same thing the mini the they're so good
I got it bab oh dude you you you
exercise you're tight you put it on it
really works as soon as it touches your
body no matter where it is you're go oh
my God and they're not a they
should be a sponsor cuz I'll
plug the you piece
send us around of them
any that's all you need the little ones
are better too but anyway I you know he
takes it out he goes he goes is this a
massage tool and I go it's a the gun he
goes a gun I was like oh you know what I
meant don't act don't say gun in
the airport to me I'm now yes I
said it but he reacted right right he's
like it's a thomb it's a pricing gun no
no come on a gun's a gun it's a cocking
gun those things are awesome the
best by the way I might I don't know if
I ever talked to you about this maybe
cuz I don't remember time but buy
yourself a pricing gun uh uh sorry a tag
a pricing tag huh go on eBay get
yourself for like six bucks seven bucks
you get the thing that puts the like the
plastic tags on the shirt that little
plastic tag you buy that yourself huh
and then whenever you want you just
whenever you buy clothes you rip the tag
off you save it if you if you're not
liking it if you don't oh this is genius
it's it's it's you got to have the tags
and you return back you take it back
that is brilliant so you make up the
price that thing no you no I just put it
right back on and return it well what I
started to do is now I never take I
don't take tags off clothes now oh I
literally don't I don't take them off I
just keep rapper I just have to
like make sure I wear it a bunch and
it's funny to say that cuz I just went
to Old Navy to buy some underwear and
I forgot to pack and I stole a
shirt cuz I feel like I'm paying
overpriced for these underwear I'm going
to steal a shirt Old Navy's whole thing
is they're not overpriced well it wasn't
my book and uh so I stole a shirt but I
didn't realize I had the doohickey the
security beep beep beep thing oh that's
that's that's big that's big so I'm
wearing this hoodie and I'm buying the
underwear I'm chatting up with the lady
she had no teeth it was in St Louis and
then uh I get to the door it goes boo
woo woo woo and I went oh I'm
and she goes you're good cuz we
had the chat up so that's my wreck so
I'm going to wear this the shirt next
time it's got the big old white
doohickey on there and I'm wearing it
all over town this a
Talented Mr Ripley it's incredible
charms people fun to wear that with it
for in perpetuity now that's on there
but when you walk in out of the stores
you're going to be setting off the
alarms well I'll never go back any store
oh good point I never shot you know what
you should do you should get them to
accuse you of stealing and then they
call the cops they detain you and then
if they're wrong that's a lawsuit that's
big that's big man that's that's why
they don't stop anyway you see all these
videos of people just walking out I know
could did the worm out of that store
with tags all over here I'm a good
citizen it is hilar it's literally like
Guys Grocery Games
sweep that's a great Point uh let me
just say this about the drugs I've been
flying with drugs for weeks now no one
has stopped me okay but I did on
accident people give me shrooms I throw
them in my bag I've been flying with
class A or whatever the hell it is class
6 drugs and one time I went to Europe
and I have the same suitcase from like
1988 you know it's like a suitcase and I
was flying to Europe and then uh the guy
goes you're in big trouble they pulled
me out of the line I was like oh
what the hell turns out I have all these
Tylenol in my bag for the hangovers yeah
it popped open and over time just
throwing the bag around it got to a
chalky powder you're kidding me so I
have all this chalky white powder all
over my bag and they're like you're
going to jail you you're a Coke Smuggler
and I'm like no no sir it's Tylenol he's
like Tylenol what the am I an idiot
and then one old Grizzle guy came in and
went he's good I got out of it that's
nuts that he'll dip a hand in your
luggage and just taste that right there
not even like cuz they got to guess they
got to make that Co in the moment but
who's but who's get gets that job who's
the guy that they say come here we need
you to do Coke right now and that's his
job oh so true an exnar guy he just
comes in he's like yeah I got thrown off
the Nar Force I played too hard now I'm
a TSA guy and I love the guy who know
they always go it's pure who's the guy
who knows the difference between pure
and unpure Coke with one taste that
guy's got a app he's like it's extra
strength but he's fine
um what about your clothing though if
you have just chalky white disintegrated
toel forever in there and you're pulling
clothes in and out of there I rarely
wear black for that reason so I could
get a new suitcase but isn't your
suitcase just unsanitary yeah you wear
the same underwear and just turn it
inside out I that's right yeah yeah I
bought new ones at Old
Navy yeah you you have um uhoh if I
ranked your hygiene from just from what
you've told me it's subaw it's subaw not
great hygiene not it's like a d you know
I wouldn't flunk you but I don't about a
d you shower a lot or no I go three
times three times or I shower every 3
days that's my rule that's not a lot
what Sumer New York dude well if you
Google showering I think it's bad for
you and if you Google Mark Norman
showering you'll get a really funny
story yeah well it's rare and the wife
hates it my balls smell like an old
coffin yeah you know you could fix that
just throw in like one extra shower here
and there yeah yeah but I think it's bad
for your hair your skin I'm telling you
the New York Times did a whole spread
about this yeah but they change their
mind every week on everything
you go to the New York Times one week
they're like coffee is bad for you the
next week they're like coffee prevents
cancer make up your mind on
coffee telling you either way I'm
drinking coffee it's good for your
natural oils in your hair maybe you know
and maybe even
your you still need to wash your ball
you're not doing any balls favors you're
not doing any balls you you got to wash
the balls no rinse if I'm going to rinse
I'm going to do the shower I just I
understand like not want to use too much
soap or I I don't shampoo too often okay
but like but I just want to
rinse it's way to do it you don't don't
shampoo oh that's not bad you hit those
ballls with a bar of soap here there
yeah maybe you're right but this could
be the wet Market thing you know
everybody's like it's from a wet Market
a pengalan lab just saying I think I'm
ahead of the
curve right what we
talkinger you met people Friday night
that's Saturday Saturday night
let me tell you something about show how
you said it you said it was every 3 days
wait a minute I might have my days off I
showered in La that's five days ago no
no La was two days ago oh okay well how
about this you how often do you work out
you work out a decent amount twice a
week no you work out more than twice a
week well what are we talking push-ups
you talking going to the gym going to
the gym twice a week you always shower
after a workout yeah that's I remember
dating a woman a while back who like
just didn't shower but she never smelled
like she smelled great naturally have
you ever smelled me be honest come here
oh God don't get in close I'm just no no
no
no not bad no I wouldn't have pegged it
for someone to sh 3 days ago okay smell
pretty good no I remember this girl like
body she would like come straight from
like a workout class and I'd be like
damn you just she was just dry smelling
good some people I don't have that I
don't shower I I don't wear deodorant
for8 hours I I've had women be like dude
you got to do something well you know
why you have that because of the
showering oh I don't know about this all
right I mean look you might be right but
I also you just proved it you said the
lady never showered you never smelled I
think it depends on the person that's
true I think there's I mean look okay
there's a homeless guy in the street he
never showers you're tell me that guy's
well this is months we're
talking I was walking through the ferry
yesterday and I you know how when it's
so thick of a smell you taste I tasted
homeless person in the air yesterday
like I literally tasted something before
I smelled it that sounds like tasted
that guy right it was like thick in the
air thick yeah that's the worst that
should be a punishment on your
show I mean taste that guy yeah they
should go to Somalia to be like he's
Asian uh lives in the Bronx do full
Somalia on that mother off during the uh
you know just tell everything about him
pandemic divorced uh he's got hepsi do
you guys have peeves we should do peeves
oh I got some peeves baby I got I always
have peeves by the way am I wreck the
Johnny Manzel doc you guys see that I
got an issue with it oh I liked it
it's fine it's just about him not it's
not not the other one the one about yeah
look it's a Netflix series where they do
the untold stories here's my issue with
some of these docks they're just
fluff pieces just speaking of docs
David
Arquette but no but I think some of
these docs are not asking hard questions
it's just like like this is my
they're not asking him it's no like he's
just like I'm fine and like clamored him
yes this dude is like clearly not fine
no what the fu is he but they did he
have a part in making it cuz sometimes
it's like they make their own and it's
just really like all of is is like a a
puff piece you know I watched one of the
ESPN ones on Dwayne Wade and his life
story is incredibly interesting but he
it was clearly like a
pre where it's like this is like you did
some bad here and they it' be like
Dwayne Wade like this many time Allstar
then he had a child out of woodlock got
back with his I'm like wow that was a
quick section and I'm like that's the
part I kind of want to hear more about
but you know uh cuz he does have an
interesting life and he was a great
player but and the Manzel is
interesting but I just wish they delved
I think it should have been it's like
one of the rare instances where it
should have been like more than an hour
10 like you know Netflix loves to
stretch a dock in like an eight hour we
like we didn't need eight hours on this
but they could have I I wanted to know
more yeah yeah but you didn't I thought
it was a fun I'm not a huge
I was on the edge of my I just thought
it could have been so much better that's
my only critique he's I mean interesting
guy Reckless player like but so
good just naturally at that level at
that level yeah true I didn't know you
were into sports at all well I love a
doc I love a story he's getting in like
backward through docks like I feel like
also I feel like through our friendship
I've like I'm such a big Sports guy that
like I've kind of should go to the game
with him yet the Knicks game no next
year for I would love to no no question
we're going to game let's do it I love
the live thing you know it's just the oh
you see they traded buer and I'm like I
don't know you know that that's too
advanced for me sefel reference from
1994 you trade J bu that's why I like
UFC though cuz to me the cool like the
Manzel stuff I'm like wow I would love
to watch this guy now so I I need the
backstory which you all know you know
about the players in the NBA we go when
we go to a game I will tell you back
story in every player cuz to me it's
just faceless people shooting a
basketball but if I get the story now
we're cooking I get that I totally I
mean when I go to Rangers games with
Gary verer verer is such a big hockey
fan that he gives me the backstory and
that gets me well he goes in the locker
room interviews him
all I can't wait to get Gary verer is SW
Illustrated um reporter he was so
adorable I mean you see these old
pictures I mean look at him he's a
Jordan Jordan the perks are
being I mean this I can't wait for his
podcast about this to come out I got to
share this I didn't know this little
Gary with John Elway wow
make a wish Phil Jackson look at that bu
cut I know wish had that bu cut right
now ah he doesn't have any hair I know
could you imagine him with the B cut
he'd be he'd be
famous damn L wow wow look at that Cindy
Crawford oh there's Michael Jordan Gary
so those you don't know what we're
talking about our buddy Gary veer's dad
was a bit of a a con man and would would
get Gary into any game he wanted using
uh fake this is back in the day where
you could use like a fake and no one
Bill Murray Bill Murray I never saw that
one he used fake credentials to get into
any sporting event saying they were
Sports Illustrated and he was photogra
for Sports Illustrated for Kids this is
a good dad right is that a good dad I
was just thinking not if you know the
whole story I'm not sure well you gotta
Ask Gary but I'm not even sure uh how
much of what percentage of that pie
chart was for him right that's my point
I think the dad wanted to go to the
games and he was like I got this I think
it was like I need to go to this game
you're a reporter you know cancer it's
almost like using a little thing as a
prop when they don't want to be there I
find it to be very
upsetting like Adam Ray with Brad
Williams deep cut deep cut hey we're
looking to get into the locker room this
is my cancer reporter
son cancer rep do you need to check his
grants I got him for both oh CRS yeah
bring him in all right you I cut you off
with a peeve because of the man uh oh
Sam's got treats in his pocket there we
go are you s dog sitting is this the
norm now no not always but no she's at
work so I'm like I got tell you I like
great position on that dog I love this
dog I I it was a classic Jack Nicholson
as good as a gets thing well I did not
like this dog At first she was snoring
everywhere and within a week I'm
holding her up like look at you you know
it really turned her around really knows
how to just chill right let's I got a
lot of peeps oh I got one I had a guy a
friend of a friend who emailed me
recently uh email heading Marvel
opportunity oo so I click on it go I'd
like you to play Loki in a YouTube
series I'm
making that ain't a Marvel opportunity
that's an opportunity to work with you a
guy who has two followers on YouTube wow
that was a lowkey prank is what that was
no he was like offended that I wouldn't
consider it oh jeez I was like I don't I
I don't it doesn't sound right for me
good luck with it and he was and he was
just like well you know it's you're
going to miss out but I'm not going to
press
and I was like all right that's the guy
who hits on a girl at a bar and she's
like no thanks he's like
Dyke she just got she's married what do
you want I had a friend that growing up
he was a drunk and he went up to
a go to Bar once he goes let's be honest
you came here to get and she was
like no I didn't and he was like oh okay
you just have to like take the L that
was his confidence level let's be honest
wow wow get
cut off no I was to say I had a
similar situation in right out of
college I came back and uh I was I
rumped into someone that I knew and they
were like what you been up to and they
like oh I'm film making now I'm
directing commercials and stuff and I
was like oh that's cool they said as a
matter of fact uh in a few days I'm
directing a CO Coca-Cola oh wow and I
was like oh cool and they were like do
you want to be in it and I was like
really and they goes yeah and I go a
Coca-Cola commercial he goes yeah
Coca-Cola I'm like Coca-Cola you've
given him five outs now go yes a
Coca-Cola commercial I was like sure are
you sure he goes yeah so he tells me
where to go and everything and I go home
and I'm like you're never going to
believe this I ran to this guy he's been
in the business now he's doing
commercial commercials and uh and I'm
I'm in the Coca-Cola commercial now I
couldn't believe I'm like man I show up
it's him with a camcorder oh no with
like three other people he printed out
his own credentials and we're on the
campus of Wagner College and uh he
doesn't even have a right to be there
and he's just walking around and he has
a case of his own cans of coke oh he
hands me the coke he's like all right
now like run over there and laugh and
open it and stuff is this Nathan Fielder
no I'm like what the hell what is like
what is this I'm like this this
this isn't a Coca-Cola
commercial so I finally was like what do
you and he's wearing a badge that says
ask me about my Coca-Cola commercial wow
yeah and so I was like uh believe you
showed up a couple yeah I well I was now
I'm into it right and now he's like oh
now we're going to a second location we
go to his home he has a pool in the yard
and it's off seon and he goes all right
I'm going to stand over here get you
know get get into shorts whatever I
guess he told me and he goes you're
going to run and jump in the air and I'm
going to throw Coca-Cola can out you're
going to catch him and dive into the
water it was like October wow and so I
was like I so I did it and then
afterwards I'm like hey like this is a
national like this is for Coca-Cola like
they know about this he's like no I'm
shooting a spec commercial to sense them
to see if I
oh wow so was about a year
ago this well technically he didn't lie
he is shooting a Coca-Cola 9s and you
know you know who that person came to be
that's James Murray the guy on my show
oh no way he Hoodwinked me completely
Christopher noan he completely
Hoodwinked me told me holy yeah
that is hilarious to this day I take him
to task for it but likey son of a
like took the day of my life also he
showed me the commercial and it looked
it was terrible is it online no I don't
think so if I could get it he did that
thing where I he did that thing where
where I jumped into the pool he reverses
it and puts it forward and reverses it
look terrible a oh man I was at that
pool three days ago I'm not joking I
believe it I know exact pool it's on
season yeah my uh my friend owns that
pool that exact pool oh Schmid G yeah
the smid gay pool yeah why were we there
yeah it's uh it's Upstate it's my my
friend my good friend uh it's an 8 and a
half acre property her grandmother owns
it and she made it into a production
house and she rents it out to places
like you know actually SNL's film there
probably 500 times what what city or
what uh no it's wow that's amazing does
say Schmitz gay on the floor no but they
have pictures of everybody who's been
there and they have the autograph schitz
gay thing and everything wow there's
with a camcorder yeah right damn well
you were going to say something like oh
no this is I mean this took my mind off
this classic
sley so she her grandma owns it and so
she just has parties there oh that's so
cool yeah where the hell is eight acres
in New York City eight and a half it's
uh I got to find out flushing where the
DG it's called the Douglas house wow
the Douglas house wow for movie and TV
and stuff that's awesome but we got
Anthony keus going to your show you're
in the Schmid's gay pool this is some
real celebrity if you're listening we
will send you merch yes I I swim in the
same water as those
gays it was awesome oh here's I got a
peeve for you all right um oh it went
away how about this the guy who goes I
hope I haven't done this pee before but
the guy who tries to give you something
that you can't do and he gets mad at you
so I had a guy at a show he goes I
brought you a big bottle of scotch and I
was like ah I can't bring that back I
can't bring on the plane he's like well
me then I'm like but I didn't ask
you to do it and I appreciate it what
kind of scotch are we talking how nice
it was pretty nice I think I can't
remember it was something I hadn't heard
of it was like uh oh maybe I have heard
of it uh cuz the question is now what's
the level of nice that you would have
checked the bag for oh if it was a
walker blue would you have checked the
bag probably I didn't even think about
checking a bag that's a good point
maybe that's what he was expecting me to
do maybe ah also you could just be like
mail it to me at the sell well
you could have shipped it home and got
it half empty you could have done
that what's scary about that is they
opened that randomly I know he must
have smelled it and they oh it smelled
okay yeah because when I got it it
smelled it didn't smell when I first put
it in and I was like oh that's a that's
a red flag but I that guy just all day
he opening up boxes it's underwear he's
like I mean you know either a piece of
or he's crafty but one of those two
he really damn I had a guy this past
weekend I was I was walking off stage
and a guy is that me it ain't me oh I'm
sorry I don't know how that's happening
this is a new watch an Apple Watch you
got this is that our kit yeah uh he
hands me he says oh dude he's right at
the front of stage he goes hey dude I
got you something he hands me three
packages of pre-rolled marijuana five in
each but it's homemade it's like it's
not it's not like homemade like like
it's like it's in packaging but it's not
the one seen a store with like a bar cod
with a manufacturer date and shout out
to you thank you very much I've had them
I brought them home but I I have yet to
smoke them because I'm a little nervous
to smoke stuff that someone handed to me
that I don't know of course but let me
out him right now I'll give a plug and
simultaneously I will implicate him if
anything goes wrong all right it says on
it gas g a s and it on the side it says
grower and a shower oh so that's the
name of the product which made me a
little weary and then there was three
kinds one was called pun Tang okay one
was called like pxi and one was a hybrid
called the pun tang pxi and I opened it
up and I I I they need a creative
meeting I opened it up and I was like I
was going to smoke it I'm like this is I
shouldn't smoke this until I find out
who this person is you know who knows
maybe he's like I also threw a little
extra in there like I Lac it you know I
don't know right right you know what I
mean so I have it uh I should have
brought it we could have that's the type
of person who would lace you and then
when you're like dude you lace
me he's like I hooked it up dude you're
welcome who is pun tang
tang tang G damn okay oh wait what is
that the mark save that for say that for
the end that's but that's uh because
it's a long clip and I show I showed my
lady it right and I was like should we
should I smoke and she's looking at and
she turns it over and she goes what does
this say a grower in the shower and I
was like I just left it at that cuz I
didn't want to get into it that's like a
mom moment I was like yeah I didn't say
anything and then like literally 10
minutes later she's like babe I'm like
yeah she goes I Googled it do you know
know what that
means I was like yeah I didn't know
you're such a weed guy you're a we guy
yeah since since late 2018 yeah well
it's better than the booze and yeah it
sounds like I'm more than I am I smoke
every day but it sounds like you don't
like weed he bought the max amount at a
at a Distillery or whatever I I'm busy I
was taking weed to sleep and I noticed
my recall was slower and I stopped that
day cold had a full- on panic attack
taking weed uh in Baltimore I woke up
and I was like I'm going to I'm
going to die my life is alive yeah g
have that effect I know I hate
the gummies dude yeah they're risky you
yeah that's the problem in the beginning
but now it's regulated so much if you
understand your dosing amount Edibles
can be really really good sure they
relax you they put you to sleep they get
you creative like all that stuff but if
you take too much it's literally it's
the worst time I've had the same
experience and when you wake up with it
cuz you go to bed not high you wake up
high in a dark room it's a it's a lot
yeah it's a lot sometimes I get so high
that I'm like how am I like I don't
think I have I can be a standup comic oh
the fraud syndrome yeah I literally I'm
like am I like there's no way I can get
on stage right now ever again like I
don't my jokes aren't good I'm not good
I don't know how I did it before I got
by but I I'm start to have a panic
attack like I I'm not going to be able
to get on stage next time and then like
you know that happened 10 times you
don't go on high do you no only two two
times in my life by accident it was
terrible but that's so crazy I took
Edibles the other night and I woke up
and I was like why is s a
comedian
no I I I feel about myself too when I
take it where I'm like I'm like what do
you do you're not funny that's
what you do you just start look like
like Larry David in the mirror you know
when he's like you that's literally
you're G to read that book you're gonna
finish the book yeah so you're GNA eat
stop eating the sugar to cut that by the
way my biggest that's my biggest
fear is getting high with a parent oh my
God that's when who's high with his dad
right yes gloma oh my God my mom high
would be my mom drunk is my mom weighs
80 lbs so my mom like has half a glass
of chardonnay in his shitfaced you know
I've been thinking about doing it with
them yeah no I really have just why not
I mean I never have and I'm I'm afraid
that's why I haven't yet but uh I just
feel like even like just a puff and just
see what happens you know see like what
what what comes out of that right for
better or worse you know ha The potheads
Who Blow The Smoke on their dog
I hate those
likes this yeah now
you got a dog freaking the out
dog's a lightweight it's a dog
never smoked weed before all one more
peeve and I'll leave you alone you ever
have this guy you go uh you go you got a
Band-Aid I cut my finger what am I a
doctor I thought you might have a
Band-Aid I love the guy who jumps to the
biggest extreme profession you know like
hey you got a screwdriver what am I a
uh NASA mechanic like NASA
mechanic be a screwdriver I love the guy
who jumps to the craziest occupation
that's a good one it's also reasonable
like I'm bleeding that's a fair idea no
I'm with you that's you got a beer what
is this the Kors Brewery no get beer in
their house I hate that guy yeah can I
have a stick of gum what am I
Walgreens no some people have gum on
them that's the guy exactly you got any
toilet paper what is this Amazon you
think I got just uh toiletries laying
around I don't know people have toilet
paper they're home
usually but you make it feel so more
obscure the better like hey you got a
piece of tape what am I
3M yeah I hate that guy the guy who's
always put out yeah everything you do
they're just like oh it's the opp the
guy who's like who's like just take it
to anything you want take that's
everyone a toast to that guy no but he's
like he's got like one like shot left in
a bottle of papy he's like you have it
you have it I don't want take the
bottle you like the painting
take the take the pen it wres upside
down take the pen look at that that's
speed there you go I ride in B Jack I
have to turn and lean on my elbow to
make the pen work I love the moment of
like he's thinking about it take the
pen
KS Real by the way
really it was that one of the exacts wow
God this actor is so good too that's the
thing about Seinfeld is be a personal
favor it would mean a lot to me I love
this is a classic old guy move this is
such a good detail there's too much
in the front shirt pocket every old guy
always does that thank you very much but
also God some of Jerry's outfits are
amazing holy red coat but but this
is such a true thing the guy who like is
like no just take it and then it's
slowly like just took my it's such
a real thing you had that old bit about
Sinatra is the painting remember that
Sinatra used to say he would anything
you would compliment he would just give
to you cuz he's like if you don't if you
can't give something away you don't
possess it it possesses you very early s
bit but my angle was like yeah that's an
easier Credo to live by when you have
hundreds of millions of dollars you know
what I mean like I'm not like someone's
like nice blanket I'm like I didn't pay
my heating bill that was my angle you
know right like no no take the beating
really take it take the
beating take the give me a personal
favor take this beating no just take it
take the clamydia I want you to have it
speaking of I got a wreck if I may all
right uh in 196 68 Joe pesi came out
with an a musical album you sent me this
did I yeah okay here it is8
68 68 68 wow Little Joe he was TI he's
what is he
52 wow this is a famous song isn't it
yeah the covers
oh
it's not great sounds like sped up
like but it's fun that it's py I can't
wait to get a seasoned assist from the
toughest Italian lawyers you think that
was funny playing his music he
worked hard on those songs
didn't he have like a little rap album
as well is that true no that was Rodney
that was Rodney play the Rodney rapping
that's incredible have you heard
rapid Rodney I got I got doubles of it
if if anybody wants one me yeah I'm here
I am I'm sining you
right I have two of them if you you can
find them and I literally see anytime I
go to a record store on the road it's in
there so like but I do have an extra if
you want it oh this is gold I think
we've played this before
but
wow oh
man I haven't heard any rap
yet there he goes my place no
respect my favorite pair no respect
respect I the same way very red wow this
is a good a good example of you got to
say no to some stuff you can't say yes
to everything hold on a second uh Joe
pesi does have a rap song it's called
wise guy in this context that was
terrible you lift those lyrics and give
them to something like a rapper and he
says that that's kind of clever actually
oh wait what was the lyric I didn't he
said my my I have them what does he say
no steak and sex my favorite pair I have
them the both I have the same way both
very rare oh that's a good line yeah my
bad boy Lil Wayne Eat Your Heart Out but
that came from the top and then made its
way down to him and it got approved and
then that whole thing had to be that so
many people thought that was a good idea
so many's like R you say all right it's
a new it's a new craze I'll tell you
right makes sense doing I get the
connection hey Run
DMC hey how about a little respect all
right I make thr to walk
oh I you know he was like probably like
he saw a dude he's probably like drugged
out a party like L Cool J and he was
like you're all right kid you're all
right give me some tips on this rep
thing both from Queens yeah there you go
bonney's Brooklyn I think is he dude I
love watching Rodney interviews on Stern
because Stern is such a big fan and
tries to go so deep and Rod he's like oh
my mother she was very difficult and
he's like what'd you do she I'll tell
you she gave me no respect he's just
doing
bits couldn't help tell was an ugly kid
too did did kids torment you I'll tell
you sh had a locker with a mop was ugly
he's like but give me more and he's like
oh my father he was no
barain yeah yeah I saw him on an
interview and uh it was Robert Downey Jr
and Howard Stern and Stern literally
he's got Robert Downey Jr on and all he
can ask him about is how great uh thank
ask how great like Rodney is working on
back to school and he's like you know
yeah you know I was very young and
Rodney at one point was like I don't
feel like shooting today and he's like
we should shoot uh we should shoot
Robert Downey's uh scenes tomorrow and
they were like oh it's not what we have
scheduled and he's like well shoot him
tomorrow he had a he wanted to see
hilarious so he like changed the
production schedule cuz he wanted to
a
prostitute it' be great if he had a
autobiography come out like years later
and it was like chapter 2 and he's like
I was so that they put me uh in a closet
with a
mop
all no I was getting deep with you it's
like the end of big fish yeah comes down
apparently got a lot of pedophiled a lot
I don't know if that's a verb he was
molested yeah molested quite a bit said
a guy would drive around the
neighborhood you you'd get in the car he
would didd you and then You' get out of
the car well wasn't that ugly a kid then
yeah good point good point uh yeah one
more oh that that was all the peeves I
have do you have any peeve s I'm sure I
have a ton David arette David arette to
peeve
uh well the guy who does hey you got to
have a shot with me I'm like but I don't
want a shot you know that's a child real
men sip yeah the shot is over I'm sorry
I appreciate the gesture oh
sorry oh you know I I was I saw
something that I almost I almost bought
you this thing I thought you would have
liked that happens yes I thought you
were serious did that to me though what
you gave me the thing you got me this
awesome I still wear it all the time I
have I have a Nick's winter beanie I
wear all the time courtesy of sell yeah
I if I see something I think people will
like I I get it you know I just but but
I but you you get that person like I I
get that a lot actually my lady does it
to me all the time she's like oh my God
I saw this thing you would have liked it
I I almost got it for you and then she
just continues what she was doing I was
like what why didn't you get it like she
she does it to me all the time to the
point now is that I hang it over her
head all the time because she I don't
get it just get me get me the
thing like don't come here and and tease
me I'm going to do that with my wife
like oh I almost proposed you know I was
thinking about I got you a wedding ring
but I didn't get
it I it doesn't work as I actually did
propose so the joke stuck but we'll keep
it moving I like this I like the joke
the thing is I live on peeves but I I
just I don't I can't pull anything up
right now I'm a great guest today no I I
have peeves I might have another hold on
let me see what I got also why don't you
plug uh your your Vic show one more time
December 2nd the Vic yeah yeah it's on
sale I it goes on sale the 15th
September 15th December 2nd at the Vic
in Chicago we're doing two and if uh you
know it's a small place hopefully they
sell out we also we're making tickets uh
a bunch of the tickets very affordable
for people that you know haven't seen me
in the past over there because I've been
through Chicago a bunch so um and uh
yeah and uh if we go we might add more
if we do it also I'm on tour completely
there's like 30 cities up there right
now so everything is at comedy.com
yeah so you guys there Cincinnati Tulsa
Wilks bar they got a great pieza place
for you in in Tulsa Savannah Georgia
Atlanta yeah mon which I'm told it's not
makon it's mon okay Georgia and then I
can't read that I can't either P
Illinois Roxford yeah I'm everywhere man
so uh salv volcano. comom salcano
comedy.com again but the Vic is the big
one guys and it's on sale September 15
if you want the uh pre-sale it's
September 13th to 14th the code is no
press no press highly recommend this
it's his first first hourong special
he's got some if you haven't seen his
stuff he's got a hilarious this is not
happening Story on YouTube show you
should watch we love him go to the show
I appreciate that and I'm going we have
doing the cruise again you guys both
been on the cruise oh wild time that's
in uh January uh January 22nd to the
26th uh to Miami to the Bahamas we're
coting with Eric Andre
oh I don't know if I'm allowed to say
this but uh is this guest confirmed you
told me about yeah oh say it wait wait
which one are you talking about a
musician we like no that was
astronomical how much he wanted as can
we say who it was well you can either
say who it was or I could tell you what
the price was and you can't say who it
was I'd rather say who it was I'd rather
who I'd rather number yeah go ahead
weird out Yankovic yeah we tried to get
him what is he that pricey yeah man I
mean he's huge you know we were just
hoping like you know he'd meet like you
know but I was hoping we get him at we
offered him a good amount but just
commands more wow but uh we we are
announcing all of the other guests like3
million for five days and there's a lot
of big ones um this I just don't know
when this com did did you decline it
with a with like a song He's like
because some
prices it was a full production you
pressed the vinyl for us who you who'
you get um I'm not allow I'm not sure if
I'm allowed to say so let me not say
okay but uh tell us afterwards I want to
know yeah there's a couple of big ones
one one has a good Synergy with us in
Eric Andre uh his name rhymes with
uh steo oh you gotta be careful with him
put a extension CT on that guy
cuz he'll jump off the boat or might
that's I don't know if that's that's
announced as of this yet and I don't
think I'm supposed to announce it but
hey well we we ran through the garden I
heard the whole thing sponsored by
Coca-Cola so uh you got some money to
around all right well thanks S I know
you got a heart out here yeah I'm good
I'm good yeah guys thank you I
appreciate you guys for on again was
great yeah absolutely happy birthday
again happy bir you through I was going
days before this guy so yes that was
that was I mean uh that was I I had a
little surprise you yours was just down
to you said the day before September oh
oh go but we know we had a surprise
thing that uh Gary verer put on for me
very small dinner but uh I know this guy
was out of town and S popped in for a
second I begged him to move it but he
wouldn't move it yeah he's a stubborn
little picked up the tab too a big
tab did he really Gary veer's a
he put a little thing he
commands you get him good meals on the
road it's it's fair it was a good meal I
walked in and uh I thought I was just
going to dinner with the lady friend and
we walked into some restaurant it's stav
Ari Gary verer Rachel Feinstein didn't
know was a surprise I actually dropped
St off I had no idea and I wasn't even
supposed to go but so I just walked in
like what the f I've never had a
surprise thing did they come over to you
by any chance the waiter or wait yeah
you sent us you sent us you all s told
me anything I like I wonder if they
didn't do it yeah even stav who doesn't
usually drink was like I'll drink with
you whoa what was it stav got Negron out
what was what did you send something
over no I just s around the streets but
I I asked them to do it and then they
said okay and then they never came no
they did they did thank you very much
for that man oh that's great what what
restaurant was it it was called vixs it
was on uh uh gr Jones I think it
yeah you'll you'll be there in Chicago
folks go see them all right I'm sad to
miss it and uh I hope there some
photos I'm going to give you guys some
photos and uh it's going to be great
let's uh let's do this right now why not
to Sal's special taping yeah here
here yours was great by the way I
watched it last week love it as usual
hilarious appreciate it thank you boys
do you know it's doing really well
online it's doing better online than on
the Netflix meaning online people made
clips and all these clips are hitting
the clips are doing well online it goes
these days apparently yeah and I think
our group is our generation of of fans
is a little younger so they go to online
before watching a full hour I don't know
but yeah it's doing well and uh we're
all we're all doing great we're we're in
a great spot life is good man uh soak it
in let's soak we love you and thank you
thank you very much love you guys thank
you boys thank you hey we we were going
to watch us anyway we we didn't want to
cheat you this clip so this is a long
clip by the way but I got right to it
here okay no but it goes on for a while
oh okay but let's see it I've never seen
this with so uh he's not Carson is it
Carson no it's Leno I believe with Leno
and it's Bert reynolds's paneling and
rnold was the first guest Mark Su is the
second guest you know he speaking of
alping like two alas two dudes I think
Bert Reynolds comes off like a bit of a
dick here okay and Mark Summers is just
trying to roll with it and I and I think
he it it's incredibly uncomfortable
television I can't wa beans and made
kids dive into it which was really great
I wish I'd seen that you
would pretty good you you make the kids
I mean you force the child you hold the
child's head under the bab and then
throw them out and I love double dare so
this whole TV thing is beneath Bert
right of course well then don't go on no
not not not the show what Mark Summers
does for a Liv oh of course yeah well
here's the thing it's like I mean that's
a funny line but look Bert you took some
payday yourself my friend you've been in
some great movies but you all I mean I
like that movie as a kid I watched that
one as a kid for sure but I just think
it's like you know this is you could
Zing him a little but he it does get a
little dickish let's keep going who told
you were neat as
freak uh I just say that cuz your back
is too mean I I I was just talking to a
back no no I I can talk to you to birk
watch out he's got scissors he's got
scissors no I was just wondering who
told you that because my my wife tells
me that often she says good morning I'm
still married as a matter of fact yes
well you o oh good for oh dump water on
him whoa jeez I think that mug me hit
him you see that yeah might have got him
in the the
face
anymore I'm all summers now it's same
here and B it's like dude you're trying
to Big Dog a dude in a pink cashm sweer
true true it's a little weird uh and you
go to violence out of the gate I mean
that's no good it's it's a a Wittier guy
versus a less witty guy who's a bigger
star and is trying to Alpha him yes this
is Dennis lry Geraldo all over again
totally and Geraldo dogged him
too exactly let's not forget Bert played
college ball let's also not forget that
he's one of the most massive movie stars
of all time hug and now it's probably
like I think there was probably a period
where he was like I'm too good for press
yeah and now he's doing press right
those think about like the Deliverance
smoking the Bandit type he's a
legend yeah look I love BR Reynolds
movies I'm not going to I'm not going to
act like I don't but but you could be
you could be a nice guest who don't come
on since Summer's
[Applause]
response away but this is good
TV this what's known as losing control
of the
program good Olden he's not a neat as
freaking
anymore oh he's a neat freak yeah I
didn't know that so Mark welcome to late
night television I know on this nice
little quiet you know Nickelodeon
lifetime we do a little show we do some
sewing we you know we do some little you
know Burt Reynolds just threw water on
me did you notice that
folks and your treasure don't touch me
yeah that a baby good for him I used to
be on your show all the time when loser
draw I used love that show funny I don't
remember all right not bad wow okay yeah
so anyway we were talking about what's
the deal why you on this guy I
think this is his brand like in the
Carson days remember he used to come on
yeah yeah he used to with people he
used to with but I don't think he's
that witty as the problem I think it's a
dude who's like thinks he's he's
surrounded by Yes Men he's so famous
yeah and I don't think he's quite as
witty as he's it doesn't come off well
totally no yeah it's talk about being
it's fanatic but you started out as a
magician if I'm not
mistaken oh
no what's this thank you about a week
and a half later it came but there we go
oh yeah good for you good for
you I didn't see that coming this is
TV wow I've never seen
this how do you like
it he's a bully this is the bully vers
Underdog Story thank you
Fabio what he
say you know I don't mind that because I
deserved it you you deserved it I
deserved it I did it to you I deserved
it okay you know that's the kind of guy
I am you know okay and I was saying to
your wife the other
night classic classic it's a classic
it's whatever you want to finish it yeah
finish it keep going I'm investing it
gets crazy
really oh this a it this ain't it been
on a very rough book tour no I saw you
with Katie Kirk you were a nice guy I
saw you on one of those PBF shows you
were very S easy to be nice to nice
people it is just it
is now he's being to see you two have
hit it off so
well doing his Milton Pearl impression
take a look at
that too obscure for the room anyway too
hit for the room I bet that place good
on
Nickelodeon there we go he's back in the
game oh count at least I have a
full-time job though that's the thing
true
I got a full-time job this
anyway what is this wait a minute can
you imagine having a small game show and
going on Leno and a A-list movie
star pck it's literally like one of us
was like the second guest with Tom Cruz
yeah and he was just like just started
poking us yes he just started
with us and I'm like dude Tom I
like you though I know I know oh this is
Top Class he's not a comic is he
marks up what did marks Su dude he was a
I don't know he might have been a comic
he might have he feels like one but he
uh he was a game show guy was a double
dare all that yeah I mean look I watched
all that so did I I love double
dare he talks we're living
so oh wait we missed something oh Leno
showed up with a pie got a coin a pie
for both of them oh this is so classic
this is like the end of Hamilton but
with a
pie oh all right all right we're we
playful I think B R's just bored
yeah he must be
2 wow oh he slipped it a little bit say
B went in with a yeah yeah face and he's
a a player br's outfit looks more
expensive oh yeah
definitely
wig oh there we go that's good
okay you know what this is you know
Leno's like well I lost control of my
show but holy I'm beating Letterman
tonight yeah oh he's got a behind the
back here hold
on oh I should have hit him with it
they're trying to get Jay I look like
this there we go
oh Jay with the
sneak this is crazy this is TV this is
TV you don't see this anymore you
definitely don't that's why it's dying
you know why cuz everyone worries about
their brand now I'll be honest I kind of
miss The Fading A-list movie star who a
who ain't pleased with it publicly
totally a publicist now would jump in
and be like that's a bad look back then
he was like shut the up I'm Bert
Reynolds yes we need that there's
something weirdly although it's not cool
Behavior there's something kind of
refreshingly honest about it yeah right
right exactly it feels genuine good for
him and this would be water cooler talk
at the at the office did you see Leno
last night exactly that's why the
ratings were weird they were number one
yeah also this is new Leno like he was
just new to the I think tonight show
ended 92 93 so he was still the young
guy can you imagine seeing that and then
like the next time Reynolds is on you're
the second guest you're like I know I
better bring it yeah don't give
him an opening yeah but all that they
had Madonna doing whatever with the
shirtless or dancing with Dave and then
Drew Barrymore did the flash like that
was fun stuff on Late Night the worst
spot ever on Late Night second panel on
Robin Williams was the first oh forget
about it he's just jumping in he's
stealing all your Thunder yeah
you know what brought Leno cuz Letterman
was number one you know what put Leno up
top Hugh Grant Hugh Grant pull it up
bang to pry got caught with a hooker and
he did Leno the next day it was a huge
headline news and Leno asked him about
it cheated on Elizabeth Hurley wow show
me the best looking woman on the planet
I'll show you a guy who gets tired of
her you got that right it's on the
bathroom wall look it's all over his
face
too yeah but I don't trust
actors who he can put who can put on a
better performance than the oh oh God I
guess I I guess I I must have made I
made a mistake yeah that was his thing
he was a little anxious a little fidgety
my ex loved him he thought he was so
hot see it's it's like when you get
cancelled the Crowd Goes
I know it just he knows he's sitting on
gold oh yeah that smile there you
go see you didn't have to pay let me
start with question number
one what the hell will you
think Leno uh what the hell you I mean
that's a great opener but also it's like
you know what bugs me about it a little
bit is there is a bit of
uh it's a little bit of like
a teacher scolding a child oh 100% it's
like it's it's like it's Leno Leno
sounds like Twitter yeah right but I
think it was in justest it was in just
but it's still like look the fact that
that's the crazy thing is like that's
your producer that's your Booker like
who's getting Hugh Grant oh yeah you
know huge huge and you know the
publicist is like you got to go on you
got to clear your name you're gonna hurt
your career so he had to go on he didn't
want to go do this but it's like he's
like I'm not a politician
exactly I didn't prom but the problem is
when you play the sweet guy in the
movies like guess who's not having to do
this apology to Bert
Reynolds Bert Reynolds would be like
yeah I the yeah he's not he
doesn't have to be like oh you know I I
made a mistake and I but it didn't hurt
his career I mean he went on to do
nodding Hill and all that God sucks
oh yeah that movie stinks I
women love that movie it's just such
chick flick horeshit
and here's my thing it's like the way
you can make a kid movie that adults
like you can make a romcom that that
dudes like and that's a straight up
chick flick yeah it's like the notebook
no guy has seen the notebook no guy no
willingly yeah yeah but love actually
was pretty good Love Actually I didn't
love either uh oh actually but uh but no
nodding Hill I was just like what a
boring ass movie so boring it's
just not funny like don't present a
movie as a romcom if it's just a ROM
what's a good ROM
Mary High Fidelity I mean something
about Mary you could say it's just a
comedy yeah with ROM in it but it
no High Fidelity Andy Hall but guess
what Andy Hall they don't end up
together so that's probably that's
probably why some cynical like us
like it broke the rules yeah I don't
know what what are good romcom to I mean
look when Harry mall is a romcom for
sure great that's a great movie great
when nor Efron even sleepus in Seattle's
pretty good yeah Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan
always kind of brought it oh yeah Tom
Hanks is just so likable I know
but then you got 10 Things I Hate About
This movie that's a good 10 Things I
Hate About You is a good movie no yeah
it is really it's very good are
you kidding me I saw it 20 years
ago I remember being bored out of my
mind that's like a fresh play on
Shakespeare that's like a great shakes
that's a great movie okay Heath
Ledger crushes that movie whoa whoa whoa
I'm thinking it's something different
what are you thinking about I'm thinking
about how to Lose a Guy in 10 Days yeah
that sucks that's what I was like wait
you're defending this with
that's a piece of poop you're right I
had the the 10 the 10 mixed me up
they're calling licorice pizza romcom
I'd agree female perspective I think
right didn't love it yeah love love that
director though I didn't see the sure
PTA meeting yeah romcoms well they put
oh they put something about marry under
there okay what else amal's great out of
sight take that's a great movie got no
Rance in the middle of it sideways I I
could see that being a romcom sideways
is incredible what about the with Jack
Nicholson that you mentioned earlier as
good as a guest that's a romcom romcom
James o Brook's a little Schmaltz but I
I like it it's very New York I I
love As Good As It Gets that's like
that's like for me a holiday Tracy Amy
is a good movie yeah I never saw that
that was on TV the other day and it was
it's one of those movies where like
Jason Lee just goes on those
misogynistic rants but they're
hilarious I gota check it out that's
that's like Kevin Smith that's like when
he was like that was like a heat check
movie when he's like all right I had
clerk to morat I got some commercial
success I'm going mature yeah he still
kept the the juvenile element
that made him good but yeah I like sh we
should get we get Kevin Smith on here oo
I would love to get him I don't know if
we'll get a word him but we can get him
on here well we got to brush up on Star
Wars or whatever the like a big
comic guy he's great though I
love Rose is a romcom who saw that
coming it is a romcom yeah I saw it
coming oh Bros yeah that slipped in the
back door
um clueless another great one that was a
good one okay we got some stuff Moon
struck is good but yeah all right is
great great movie Nicholas Cage
Nicholas Cage is like you don't know
what you're going to get but when you
he had a weird career trajectory
he got like ton of gambling debts and he
had to do Ghost Rider 8 you know and
Gone in 60 Seconds and I don't know what
he's doing now he just did that one
about him was like that fun good was it
good okay I never saw it it's silly as
it's insane it's a fun meta twist
you know I like it me too Michael Peña
who he the other who's the other guy no
it was the guy from the last he's great
yeah he is gooded Pascal there it is
Michael PNE is good too though
him you know he is he's in
everything oh yeah you know him good
character actor yeah great actor oh of
course he's in everything everything
dude uh yeah no Nicholas Cage was in pig
that was a great movie oh I loved Pig
what a weird movie beautiful mie
movie uh something else we were going to
talk about movies are in a weird place
you know it just doesn't I don't know
like you get Top Gun or Barbie or
Oppenheimer and it it helps but I just
don't feel like you can have an indie
anymore can you have a Pulp Fiction of
My Big Fat Greek Wedding you know and
you you SC probably even deeper in like
the way that you go you gotta go so deep
in your own pocket yeah swingers
a Reservoir Dogs a swingers he's right I
mean it's like it's a risk it's such a I
mean I I yeah cuz I just don't think you
make your money back now I think if
you're an investor like why would I
help a young filmmaker when I
Marvel opportunity for
you do I get to play Loki cuz I've
always wanted to do that L it's good I
feel bad I've had kids bring me scripts
at a show and I'm like I'll never read
this this is 200 Pages I'm not going to
read it not accept them never them they
go through your agent because he'll say
if you come out with anything in the
future that's kind of like that like I
handed him a script he he accepted it oh
sh and he copied my idea interesting has
to go through your agent is what they
say okay that's how Mark came out with
Oppenheimer
too the biggest bombing yes that'll be
the name my next
special well it maybe we should
wrap this bad boy up wrap her up where
you going to be the 12th oh no so I'll
be in uh York and Bethlehem Pennsylvania
this weekend followed by Toronto uh
September 21st I believe it's the
Meridian theater is that what it is yeah
that's a big one I it's big it's a
beautiful theater I'll be at the Chicago
Theater September 30th
IES uh Phenix stand up live yeah I'm
doing a lot of clubs coming up to really
tighten up the for the next special but
stand up live in Phoenix October 5th
through 7th Pittsburgh uh October 25th
that's Nick's home opener so you better
show up for that cuz I
could have gotone a Nick Celtics
Cleveland at the uh Miami
Ohio Theater that's what it's called
weird Mimi Ohio I can't see I'm blind
then we'll be that same weekend Columbus
Ohio Cincinnati Indianapolis the big one
uh November 4th New York City the
theater at MSG for the festival November
4th sell.com shows we also got Brisbane
Melbourne Adelaide Sydney Australia and
we just added Vegas at the win it's my
second time in Vegas this year cuz you
know I can't get enough of that Vegas
that's December 2nd and then the
following week we got Tampa and
Naples Mario area it's
back brother yeah end on a bang all
right all right I'll be in Europe this
whole time so come out and see me in
Amsterdam antor Berlin Dublin London
Glasgow uh Birmingham yes and then back
at Hershey Pennsylvania OCT tickets are
are hurting so come to Hershey get a
Hershey ticket and get an Oklahoma City
ticket those are hurting too
raping us raping these fees these
add-ons it's too much it it's so weird
where you're like I was looking at my
MSG thing just to see how tickets were
doing and the lowest price ticket with
their dumb fees $82 oh because of their
fees dude these are not expensive
tickets they're like more than my
prices it's well no it's
not Taylor prices but uh crazy but it's
it's crazy man so I finally have
something to plug oh the r look at that
yes shot a full spread this is pretty
cool see U for the D open oh this is
hilarious I mean look at look at girl
here uh Janelle oh she's a comic they
want a little diversity for Lane you
know this is great look at this
yeah we uh reshot we reshot every
Seinfeld tennis scene and I cast it with
all Comics this is hilarious Judy Gold
on the back this is great very good
Sally killed it they're giving them out
at the open if you're there or if you
were
there getaz this too we got great look
at that I know it's the best she's ever
looked and stavos killed it as George
look at that with the the ice cream
sunde come on this is so good thank you
so good Sally K we went out to what was
it Forest Hills or somewhere somewhere
flushing who the hell knows super fun
hilarious he got our Ubers it was very
nice so we appreciate that thank you
Sally look up racket Bodega cat whiskey
atacat whiskey.com we're now legal in
Georgia and we're closer and so close to
New York I'm getting hit up by so many
people let's make New York
happen once it happens this will
explode New York City Bodega cat let
do this let's do it it's online
so go get it online people keep say how
do I get it go to Bourbon outfitters.com
I want to say so get a bottle and or
beraat whiskey.com oh even better yeah
better all right thank you folks we'll
see you all in Hell
comedy good
[Music]
asso and's talking sh
and I get down
the the roof
cop naked Samu
iser I'm out toch in
[Music]
orans
might
be
true
[Music]